the setup is simple all you need is an
android device a USB cable and your
development machine let's take a look
before you get started you need to turn
on the developer mode in your Android
device this may be different on any
given device and you can check your
device's manual for how to do this in
many cases though you need to go to your
device's settings click on about device
and then click on build number seven
times seriously next you'll want to turn
on USB debugging again this varies
slightly on your given device but this
is usually located in the developer
options we also need to make sure we
have the right tools installed on my
laptop I have Chrome Canary and on my
mobile device
I have Chrome Beta installed